[Music]
i promise you
i can teach you how to play drums in
about two minutes oh
come on here we go the first time i
played i was five years old
i learned how to play by watching my dad
this is the foundation of who i am
every single piece of me is in these
drums
everything
one two three go in this master class
i'm going to teach you how to find your
rhythm
the fundamentals of percussion and
drumming and how to perform with a band
some funk beats can be a little more
complicated
[Music]
it's still in time but it makes it funky
now this next beat consists of
three sounds so the first one is
and then a slap my right hand is gonna
keep time
someone said to me you're a woman who
said that you can be the best i said i
can be the best
come on up if you don't have drums
that's okay
pick up an instrument do something play
and enjoy yourself and make it fun
because when you know what your passion
is and what your purpose is
and you go for it no one and nothing can
stand in your way
[Music]
i'm sheila e
and this is my master class
[Music]
[Music]
you